at a press meeting at the bomb 25
filming location in Jamaica a few days
ago the cast the director and the
producers met to announce some details
about the upcoming film right on time
for the start of shooting behind the
scenes the experienced Bond script
writers Neil Purvis and Robert Wade were
hired it was also announced that Daniel
crack in his role as agent Bond will
make the last appearance in his mi6
career not an active service but in a
self-selected and rather idyllic retreat
in Jamaica hardcore fans of the bun
series will surely make one or two
connections to Jamaica after all not
only band creator Ian Fleming has
written all Bunn novels there but also
the first part of the serious plays in
parts of the Caribbean island state in
addition to the story the official cast
list of 125 was also revealed but there
are no real surprises among others
rami malek was already associated with
bond 25 was now officially confirmed as
Bond villain Daniel Craig as James Bond
Roth finds as M Naomi Harris as
Moneypenny and many more return to their
old roles a possible return of Christoph
Waltz as Blofeld is rather unlikely but
not impossible as cary fukunaga said
between the lines we will surely get
more information about the new
unfortunately still untitled bond film
during the shooting and also the release
on April 10th 2020 is not that far away
in the future either a few days ago the
first official scenery from the upcoming
issue was published however against all
expectations there are no creepy horror
pictures to be seen but James McAvoy in
the role of buildin bro the plot of it -
follows 27 years after the first part
and will be rich in shock moments again
since the losers Club reunites to expel
the evil clown Pennywise from their
hometown Derry the young actors of the
first part have now logically been
replaced by their adult counterpart
although there is also supposed to be a
little reunion with the young stars of
the first part in any case a first
trailer should be expected soon
as the release date on September 6 2019
is only four months away next month the
new r-rated ec-series Swamp Thing will
be released the 10 episode horror series
is based on a 1971 release DC comic and
has
already reached a wider audience in 1989
with the return of swarm thing the
Sirius is supposed to be about a
scientist named Alex Holland who is
researching preparations to enable
people to survive under difficult
conditions however a terrible accident
happens to him which causes him to merge
with the plants living in the swamp to
become a swamp creature according to the
author
Gary Doberman the aim of an age
restriction is to make swarm thing as
creepy as possible Swamp Thing will be
released on DC Universe on May 31st
besides a picture released from the
upcoming it - they are also news from
the conjuring series which also
published a kind of post on the occasion
of the upcoming third part in an
interview with film starts director
Michael chase also revealed some details
about conjuring three James Wedmore the
actors behind the camera anymore but
we'll head over to his colleague chase
and also in front of the camera a lot
changes with the renunciation of the
haunted house or at least in terms of
the crew the two leading roads with
Patrick Wilson and Rara famiglia
shouldn't change too much the shooting
in Atlanta will start in a few weeks but
at the moment the focus is on Lorraine
Warren who died a few days ago at the
age of 92 and who had a big influence on
the portrayal of her role by Vera
Farmiga the release date of conjuring 3
will be next year at the end of this
year the new streaming service this
necklace will finally be launched
not only the big announced new projects
like the mandalorian and several marble
series will be featured but also the old
film classics however there are rumours
that is they will only release a
censored version of some of the older
movies certainly one of them will be
sang up the south which was released in
1946 but which will be known to very few
of you the reason for this is supposed
to be a glorifying representation of
slavery another much better known case
is Dumbo the flying elephant in specific
terms a scene in which a group of growls
lends the protagonist Dumbo a feather
with which she can fly one problem is
the african-american accent of the
grouse and the other is the name of the
leader Jim Crow who bears unsurprising
resemblance to the stereotype of a less
intelligent african-american of the same
name used in the 19th century it remains
to be seen whether these rumors
turn out to be true in the end however
due to Disney's family-friendly image it
is quite likely and Landers endgame is
dominating cinemas all over the world in
its first days after the release in the
US and Canada the new Marvel blockbuster
landed on more screens than any film
ever has in North America this is like
the hundred year flood of movies said
Paul the Garabedian senior media analyst
for comScore the current opening-weekend
record is held by the last Avengers
movie the 2018 preamble to end king
infinity war it deputed with 368 million
domestically and nine hundred thirty
million u.s. dollars worldwide however
the only thing standing in the way of an
game is end game itself with its running
time of 181 minutes theaters won't be
able to fit as many screenings in per
day as they'd like to the goro billion
says that the demand is going to
outstrip the supply but theaters are
doing their best to keep up
[Music]